last week I attended VidCon VidCon is a
conference slash convention organized by
the two brothers Hank green and John
Green also known as the vlog brothers
also known as two of my favorite people
in the entire world ever I've been every
single year although this is the first
year that I got myself the t-shirt and
every single year
apparently I make an effort to do
something crazy the first year I took my
trousers off on stage to reveal the
second pair of trousers underneath the
second year I took my trousers off on
stage to reveal my boxes underneath and
so naturally this year I decided to try
and meet as many people as I possibly
could over the two main days of the
conference because I didn't want to have
to take my trousers off again on the
first day I did do a brief talk in front
of a scarily large number of people I'm
not gonna be taking off my pants this
year to tell everyone to please go and
visit my signing booth which I had set
up the day before this is what my booth
look like I designed myself a banner and
a new t-shirt and brought a bunch of
Myrtle long including a brand new poster
designed by Von Dale Swain and I hired
my friends Adam and Todd to help run the
booth with me and generally I became
very stressed over planning for
something for which ultimately all I had
to do was show up and write on things
for people on the first day of signing I
was joined by my friends and fellow
chameleon circuit family members Liam
Dryden who came to sign for a couple of
hours and Michael Aranda who came to
sign for a couple of hours as well but
ended up staying for the whole thing
because he said he had nothing else to
do I have a feeling I would have gone
crazy I considerably earlier on in the
day if it hadn't been for having Michael
by my side for the whole thing so thank
you for signing with me my calls and
statistics from day one because
everybody loves statistics in total we
met 816 people we signed for about six
hours the longest people had to wait in
line to meet us was about two hours I
got one photo with this girl one friggin
pull gun replica and at least one person
cried which after I got home and saw the
footage from that evening made me feel
sort of weird and emotional day number
two was pretty much the same except we
started two hours earlier and as the day
went on I finally started to question
whether or not doing 16 hours of signing
in two days was actually physically
possible some other noticeable
differences today to include the girl
with the portal gun being replaced by
two awesome girls dressed as link
wheeler a wild Felicia Day appearing to
give me a shoulder rub because she
thought I looked tired oh and also I
went so crazy doing so much signing that
I felt like I was gonna be sick which I
didn't tell you what
at the time because I was embarrassed by
it but that's how I felt fortunately we
didn't have to turn anybody who had been
waiting away from the line we just cut
the end of the line off a couple of
hours early and in total I met 1589
people I want to keep going in my heart
my head is like you have to go to bed
so I'm gonna do that I didn't really
enjoy last year's VidCon massively and
the reason for that I think is because
I'm a very shy person and as a shy
person VidCon is quite an intimidating
experience for me as a way of dealing
with my shyness last year what I did
essentially was hide away in my hotel
room for the entire conference and ended
up avoiding people who may have come to
VidCon to meet me and that just made me
feel really really bad so that's why I
decided to go in the opposite direction
this year the direction of meeting so
many people that had actually made me
feel ill because it's the best thing
that I could think of to do to try and
give something back to this amazing
community of people who watch the online
video give me the opportunity to call
this my job I'm so thankful to be able
to do this and it's so lovely to be
reminded that you're all real people and
that you know a viewcount doesn't matter
as much as a single interaction with a
person who genuinely cares about what
you do so thank you thank you so much
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool to lighten the
mood I will now play the Super Mario
Brothers theme tune on my face here we
go yay bye